Speaker 1: The legal problems for conspiracy
theorist Alex Jones and four former Trump
associate Roger Stone continue. And you might
remember that on the one hand, Roger Stone was
convicted and subsequently pardoned, but he
had has had his fair share of legal trouble.
Alex Jones is in the middle of multiple lawsuits,
including some related to his conspiracy theories
and false claims of a false flag in the context
of the Sandy Hook shooting back in 2012.
And they both now have even more legal troubles.
Alex Jones and Roger Stone have been subpoenaed by
the House panel investigating the Jan. six riots.
The panel said it subpoenaed Trump spokesman
Taylor Budda, which Republican political operative
Roger Stone and conspiracy monger Alex Jones,
as well as two others in a report by CNBC.
The House panel says the new recipients,
who have been asked for testimony and documents,
are believed to have knowledge of the plans
and funding for the rallies on January 6th. Now
we're going to see whether they actually respond
to these subpoenas or whether they will end up
being held in contempt. But these are clearly
key figures, and there's a few different things to
think about Alex. Steve Bannon has also now been
indicted for his ignoring of a subpoena from this
committee, so a few different things. Number one,
it really seems like Alex Jones is an important
figure in the Jan. six Trump riots the day before
the riots. There's a video that was posted to his
website Infowars.com, which shows him telling a
crowd in Freedom Plaza in Washington, D.C. We have
only begun to resist the globalists or globalists,
as he says. We have only begun to fight against
tyranny. They have tried to steal this election
in front of everyone. I don't know how this is all
going to end, he said. But if they want to fight,
they better believe they've got one. That was
the night before the Jan. six riots. This guy
seems to be up to his eyeballs involved in
this thing, and he has now been subpoenaed.
Roger Stone has now been subpoenaed. Trump
spokesman Taylor Budo, which has been subpoenaed
and of course, Stephen Bannon, ignored his
subpoena and has now been indicted for that.
Will we ever really learn the full scope of
the planning that the preplanning that went
on? I don't know if we will. I really don't.
But it's pretty clear that these guys are up
to their eyeballs in the stuff, and the Jan. six
committee should keep going and going and going.
There may not be political consequences. In fact,
unfortunately, I think there probably will not be.
The elected officials who were involved
are mostly in safe red districts,
in safe red states or not even up for reelection
when it comes to senators in the immediate future.
And they will most likely all get reelected
and there probably won't be legal consequences
for them. But when it comes to people like Alex
Jones, whoever they can get, they should pursue
if that's where the evidence points. And that
is absolutely where the evidence is pointing
right now. So continued legal trouble for Alex
Jones and others, and we'll see what comes of it.